no it's cuz it's a bad timing say that I
have no respect for females me you don't
see that storm
you know I be that my momma played a big
part and who I am to that you know I'm
saying I'd be that she could have done
something to prevent all the [ __ ] that
I've been through you I'm saying
if you just said say [ __ ] it I'm gone
you don't see but no she stayed
first-first where'd you grow up I was
born and raised in California I Manion
grew up in the city of Los Angeles and
you grew up with butter pants rolled
with appearing in that what do you mean
by a pair of the half will our mother
she was very loving I said to my dad
it was a beast he's a monster
you know so you wouldn't care he was a
monster and my way you know he would use
his piston I mean the vichy he is you
don't give us stop using he would go out
sometime get shrunk come back two or
three or four o'clock in the morning
starting on my mama you know understand
and we would have to leave the house at
whatever time it was between those hours
you know machine and my mother did not
drive at the time you know
and she has 62 kids she had to put along
with her and we have to get industries
involved just to get away from you know
love was not a word that was spoken in
my household you know yes because my
parents didn't know what love was real
machine and so Bernie knows that even
though I can recall this your lye ditch
hole the crazy stuff us this crazy stuff
so I'm finding another world room this
was like crazy and and what my parents
are from Arkansas one Scene one coupon
bluff and one from their rocker and my
father sobs ward need more floors the
concrete and my mother was more like a
city girl you know but you know even I
guess when my father were growing up the
same kind of stuff is going on in his
house all using you know our family a
fight shoot
wherever Jesus have such means are the
normal process to lose another French
economy and you know some time are dead
within a moment and I can recognize in
fact the elephant one that I don't think
you know bother all one time you know
gaining employment that you know and I
just internalize what humorous careful
Pinos using and I just because I've
lived my mom even stand up
music so the obliterating fulfilling
using
it is cold because if I can't trust a
female international structure in shame
and get someone in return you know so
you go to life good an anomaly in USA so
you know your child has a really [ __ ]
me up your the dish that my mother
suffered renouncing and how she can
change to better go on
I'm sorry I said how she continuously to
let it go on you know and that's where
you know my animosity you my fuel of
betrayal
continue continue but only know you know
and me as a kid you know spending things
that can be done you know same
yeah I mean no on two occasions my
father did my mama so I'm under the
illusion I'm under the belief that she
was pair of shoes time Johnson because
you know I went where she went
no they saw near miss reports up to the
border I suppose you know you know music
here well spelling out who I was you
know to be announced ready you know
important changes sometimes when my mom
ran i delegated open at 339 place to
always say I've been in this world and
I'll take you out nonsense so that's not
to be fighting to achieve me when you
hear that are brought into this world in
our technical means time you kidding
then you know we walk of the program
were drunk men or a person understand
and you know I just I think I'm um
you see I've been my mama campaign
being here that didn't do anything
you know it's so you know pink those
Falls I just believe that you're never
bored right you know they in Delhi
you feeling your mother's child you
feeling mother's boy
you feel like your mama let it happen
then she changed it ready go on yes you
know and being a kid not for myself I
promised myself that I would never do
that my daddy no you know what I ain't
her to be just like you
where are the personality traits he
needed you impressive news
no record it selfishness personality
traits a girl needs to work it's secure
no self-esteem in Tucson you desire to
be something more than she is
I'm saying in she has to have trust
Jesse had truck that I'm gonna be the
one to bring her from where she had to
what she want to go
here close no no they bring their money
to me not take care of me
you see other piece might bomb Falls and
[ __ ] no [ __ ] not me you know whatever I
do
that's what then bad did you wear about
state that's where they stay you see so
I don't providing with no lushness
housing and that [ __ ] no alias I'm
60 years old and all those 60 years is
for public record you know if you go
back I can guarantee you that our party
done at least 25 of those years in
prison you see I get all my psyche
killed I went to prison either 18-year
sentence in 1992 PennDOT you know
because see nothing that they had that
ride and I believe that about a deer
live in trouble but every minute of my
thirties I sneaked in prison you know
started at Pelican Bay
you know supposed to be I guess the
hardest prison in the state of
California felony felony there was the
best present I ever went to
yeah I've been to a hospital
I got a Gillian's 41 years old
I'm almost leaning on that eyebrows 41
so all those middle days and years was
spent in person every minute of what
were you doing 18 years for um I got
this sense for a host the real bad
things you see
ATW Mayhem's robberies you know that's
the kind of stuff I understood
I was hurt so bad as she emotionally
physically
I told myself you know the pack you're
paying someone else's sonic good at you
know it's terrible to this day you see
unfortunately you know I've taken a good
morning I'm gonna check what if I feel
like you won in prison tango me
we're the best in me you know I shall
respect many many women to me there's a
little difference you see I don't want
nobody to be like me you know and you
think that I'm Nelson
I haven't ordered one she just [ __ ]
nice place thank you for allowing me to
[ __ ]
you